Today I'm speaking about
the first of the three great
partial differential equations.
So this one is called Laplace's
equation, named after Laplace.
And you see partial derivatives.
So we have-- I don't have time.
This equation is
in steady state.
I have x and y, I'm
in the xy plane.
And I have second
derivatives in x and then y.
So I'm looking for
solutions to that equation.
And of course I'm given
some boundary values.
So time is not here.
The boundary
values, the boundary
is in the xy plane,
maybe a circle.
Think about a circle
in the xy plane.
And on the circle, I
know the solution u.
So the boundary values
around the circle are given.
And I have to find
the temperature
u inside the circle.
So I know the temperature
on the boundary.
I let it settle down and I want
to know the temperature inside.
And the beauty is, it solves
that basic partial differential
equation.
So let's find some solutions.
They might not match
the boundary values,
but we can use them.
So u equal constant certainly
solves the equation.
U equal x, the second
derivatives will be 0.
U equal y.
Here is a better one, x
squared minus y squared.
So the second derivative
in the x direction is 2.
The second derivative in
the y direction is minus 2.
So I have 2, minus 2,
it solves the equation.
Or this one, the second
derivative in x is 0.
Second derivative in y is 0,
those are simple solutions.
But those are only
a few solutions
and we need an infinite
sequence because we're going
to match boundary conditions.
So is there a pattern here?
So this is degree 0, constant.
These are degree 1, linear.
These are degree 2, quadratic.
So I hope for two cubic ones.
And then I hope for
two fourth degree ones.
And that's the pattern,
that's the pattern.
Let me find-- let me
spot the cubic ones.
X cubed, if I start with x
cubed, of course the second x
derivative is probably 6x.
So I need the second y
derivative to be minus 6x.
And I think minus
3xy squared does it.
The second derivative
in y is 2 times
the minus 3x is
minus 6x, cancels
the 6x from the second
derivative there, and it works.
So that fits the pattern,
but what is the pattern?
Here it is.
It's fantastic.
I get these crazy polynomials
from taking x plus iy
to the different powers.
Here to the first power, if n
is 1, and I just have x plus iy
and I take the real
part, that's x.
So I'll take the
real part of this.
The real part of this when
n is 1, the real part is x.
What about when n is 2?
Can you square
that in your head?
So we have x squared and we
have i squared y squared,
i squared being minus 1.
So I have x squared and
I have minus y squared.
Look, the real
part of this when n
is 2, the real part
of x plus iy squared,
the real part is x
squared minus y squared.
And the imaginary
part was the 2ixy.
So the imaginary part that
multiplies i is the 2xy.
This is our pattern when n is 2.
And when n is 3, I take
x plus iy cubed, and that
begins with x cubed like that.
And then I think that
the other real part
would be a minus 3xy squared.
I think you should check that.
And then there will
be an imaginary part.
Well, I think I could figure out
the imaginary part as I think.
Maybe something like
minus-- maybe it's
3yx squared minus y cubed,
something like that.
That would be the real
part and that would be
the imaginary part when n is 3.
And wonderfully,
wonderfully, it works
for all powers, exponents n.
So I have now sort of a pretty
big family of solutions.
A list, a double list,
really, the real parts
and the imaginary
parts for every n.
So I can use those
to find the solution
u, which I'm looking for, the
temperature inside the circle.
Now of course, I have
a linear equation.
So if I have several
solutions, I can combine them
and I still have a solution.
X plus 7y will be a solution.
Plus 11x squared minus
y squared, no problem.
Plus 56 times 2xy.
Those are all solutions.
So I'm going to find a
solution, my final solution
u will be a combination of this,
this, this, this, this, this,
this, and all the
others for higher n.
That's going to be my solution.
And I will need that
infinite family.
See, partial
differential equations,
we move up to infinite family
of solutions instead of just
a couple of null solutions.
So let me take an example.
Let me take an example.
We're taking the
region to be a circle.
So in that circle, I'm looking
for the solution u of x and y.
And actually in a circle,
it's pretty natural
to use polar coordinates.
Instead of x and y
inside a circle that's
inconvenient in the
xy plane, its equation
involves x equals square root of
1 minus y squared or something,
I'll switch to polar
coordinates r and theta.
Well, you might say
you remember we had
these nice family of solutions.
Is it still good in
polar coordinates?
Well the fact is,
it's even better.
So the solution of u
will be the real part
and the imaginary part.
Now what is x plus
iy in r and theta?
Well, we all know x is r Cos
theta plus ir sine theta.
And that's r times Cos
theta plus i sine theta,
the one unforgettable
complex Euler's formula, e
to the I theta.
Now, I need its nth power.
The nth power of
this is wonderful.
The real part and imaginary
part of the nth power
is r to the nth e
to the in theta.
That's my x plus iy to the nth.
Much nicer in polar
coordinates, because I
can take the real part and
the imaginary part right away.
It's r to the nth Cos n theta
and r to the nth sine n theta.
These are my solutions,
my long list of solutions,
to Laplace's equation.
And it's some
combination of those,
my final thing is going to
be some combination of those,
some combination.
Maybe coefficients a sub n.
I can use these and
I can use these.
So maybe b sub n r to
the nth sine n theta.
You may wonder what I'm
doing, but what I'm achieved,
it's done now, is to
find the general solution
of Laplace's equation.
Instead of two
constants that we had
for an ordinary differential
equation, a C1 and a C2,
here I have these guys
go from up to infinity.
N goes up to infinity.
So I have many solutions.
And any combination working,
so that's the general solution.
That's the general solution.
And I would have to
match that-- now here's
the final step and not
simple, not always simple--
I have to match this to
the boundary conditions.
That's what will tell me
the constants, of course.
As usual, c1 and c2 came from
the matching the conditions.
Now I don't have just c1 and
c2, I have this infinite family
of a's, infinite family of b's.
And I have a lot more to
match because on the boundary,
here I have to match
u0, which is given.
So I might be
given, suppose I was
given u0 equal to the
temperature was equal 1
on the top half.
And on the bottom half, say
the temperature is minus 1.
That's a typical problem.
I have a circular region.
The top half is held
at one temperature,
the lower half is held at
a different temperature.
I reach equilibrium.
Everybody knows that
along that line,
probably the temperature
would be 0 by symmetry.
But once the temperature
there halfway up, not so easy,
or anywhere in there.
Well, the answer is u in
the middle, u of r and theta
inside is given by that formula.
And again, the ANs
and the BNs come
by matching the-- getting the
right answer on the boundary.
Well, there's a big theory
there how do I match these?
That's called a Fourier series.
So I'm finding the coefficients
for a Fourier series, the A's
and B's, that match a
function around the boundary.
And I could match any
function, and Fourier series
is another entirely
separate video.
We've done the job with
Laplace's equation in a circle.
We've reduced the problem
to a Fourier series problem.
We have found the
general solution.
And then to match it to
a specific given boundary
value, that's a
Fourier series problem.
So I'll have to put that off
to the Fourier series video.
Thank you.